mr. president word broke late today
early this evening that there might be
some tentative deal struck to avert a
government shutdown what can you tell us
well I can tell you that a lot of things
have changed and we'll see what happens
I can't go into the exact deal I just
heard it very quickly coming over to see
you is between the deal and you and I
had to choose you because I have no
choice right and I'm very happy I did
but yeah they're talking and we'll see
what happens there's an opposing rally
kind of going on at the same time as
this rally tonight Bader O'Rourke young
kind of up and comer they say in the
Democrat Party he and others say the
wall is really about hate and racism to
to to that you say what well to that I
say that number one very few people
showed up to his rally and this place is
packed with thousands and thousands
outside and I guess he challenged us to
an event so maybe this means he's gonna
have to drop out of the race because
this was a not a good situation for him
I don't know why he did it and it has
nothing to do with anything other than
safety for the Americans safety for our
people safety for our country and a wall
is a very good thing not a bad thing
it's a moral thing to put it in the
opposite terms and we have tremendous
support we're building it right now we
don't even say build the wall anymore we
say finish the wall because we've built
a lot and we're renovating a tremendous
amount of all stuff that was really in
bad shape but it had good structure so
we're saying finish the wall no walls
are very important if you don't have it
all of the technology Laura all of the
drones that they are flying around so
nicely up in the air they don't mean a
thing what about all these border
sheriffs the ones at the border border
mayors they oh no we don't need what
we're safe they were challenging some of
your statistics on El Paso even though
Horace has had a terrible year last year
four murders another one over Juarez is
like the murders are tremendous and here
they are very few they are not correct
they know they're not correct and they
say the crime is low low resolve was
very high and then the wall got built
and you know really you should talk
about the sheriff's that agree with me
which are like 98 percent of the
sheriff's of the country maybe
all of them detention beds that they
threw that out we're gonna reduce the
number of detention beds what was that
all well when you do that and the
Democrats came up with that because that
means that you don't detain people that
are very dangerous that means you have
to put them out into our society because
our laws are so bad and if you look at
what happened and what's been passed
over the years in Congress it's a shame
it's a disgrace that means we can't just
put them back into Mexico or where they
came we have to put them back into our
society in some cases they're stone-cold
criminals we can't do that another good
piece of economic news came out today
personal confidence in the economy I
think it's at a 16 year high with that
why are so many Millennials gravitating
in some polls towards socialism over
capitalism and what can you do to
reinvigorate their understanding of the
free market well I think they're noble
when they're young they're idealistic if
you call it idealistic I think that
capitalism is more of an ideal but if
you look at the poll numbers you look at
the kind of numbers that we have it's
been great I hit my all-time high today
52 percent and that's with only bad
soars because the press only gives me
bad sirs you treat me fairly were you
surprised when some Democrats didn't
stand up when you asked that question at
the State of the Union about socialism
or we're never going to be a socialist
country not everybody stood up because
that's where they're coming from when I
see some of the responses when I see
some of the statements made by Congress
men and women I am are we living in the
United States of America look we have a
country that's doing the best it's ever
done
we are just lapping the world you
compare you know it used to be like we
were a second sister to China now China
is looking up to us we are doing so well
and other countries are not doing well
and that makes it tougher for us in a
certain way because we do business with
other countries but we're setting
records in so many ways including record
unemployment meaning in a positive way
meaning but they always say well the
Obama started that and then they'll say
well there's income inequality that's
the new buzzword you're gonna hear that
a lot in 2020 income inequality a lot of
the young freshman congressman and the
some of the some of the candidates in
2020 are really gravitating toward
they've I read have stayed with what
President Obama did you look at his last
months you look at what happened the
first months coming into my term they
were very low the numbers the GDP
numbers and everything else if I would
have stayed with those numbers
we would have had an economy that would
have been going way in Reverse right now
we opened it up we got rid of relay
regulations that were unnecessary we did
the biggest tax cuts we've ever done in
our country we opened up the oil we
opened a you know with the largest oil
exporter now with the largest oil and
gas in the world right now nobody
thought that was possible this quickly
no we opened up our country we're
letting people work again we have more
people working today almost a hundred
and sixty million people we have more
people working today than have ever
worked in the United States it's great
yeah we didn't have some people stand
for that at the State of the Union you
say record low unemployment well what
does that tell you about are they
I got a lots of text they're trying to
paralyze our economy with investigations
all these oversight you're getting
hammered I know it with requests for
documents and so forth which is part of
the oversight well what's happened
what's going on there yeah what's
happened to me should never be allowed
to happen to another president with
investigations on things that never took
place like Russia you know the Russia
collusion delusion we call it the I call
it a hoax and in fact it was very nice
Richard Burr the other day came out
after almost two years of investigation
they found absolutely no collusion
between Trump and the Russia which I
could have told a lot of people and
which I have been saying to a lot of
people this has never happened to its
the Democrats know it's a hoax this is a
political game so now the Russia thing
is dead and now they say well we're
gonna look at every company that Donald
Trump was ever they don't have any
information on anything we're gonna look
at every company that Donald Trump was
ever involved in I did great I made a
lot of money now they want to go back
and investigate every company we want to
go and we have I think 79 different
letters from different committees now
you're gonna respond to these letters
well for the most part they're
conflicted I got one I got one from
Pocahontas today where it said that
Donald Trump we want to investigate some
company that it's so disgraced so I said
just write her back say she's got a
conflict of interest okay and she should
focus more on her heritage and not being
ashamed of what she is she should really
focus on herself but we've gotten
letters learn from so many committees I
didn't know we had
so many committees I think it's up to 79
letters this is based on no information
of any wrongdoing because I'm a very
straight person so in America so we went
through this whole Russian hoax nobody's
ever done what I did where I was hit
with this now we think of this hit with
it and we probably had the greatest
first two years of any president in our
history in terms of what we've
accomplished with employment with GDP
with everything and companies are moving
back into a country which is one of the
great stats african-americans in this
country what would you say to the young
african-american today in Virginia who
is seeing the turmoil in that state and
just it wants to kind of understand what
the race issue is like pulling us on all
sides terrible situation I think that
the Republicans are going to do very
well in Virginia I think a lot of things
are happening in Virginia
I didn't campaign in Virginia because I
said I was told that a Republican quite
a few stops very good virtually not but
yeah it started looking at numbers I
said why aren't I there but but I didn't
you know they they sort of assumed that
that's a Democrat state and as you know
I did very well there without having gun
I think Virginia is ready to flip over
to something and I'll tell you
african-americans are coming to the
Republican Party like nobody can believe
a lot of things are happening a lot of
very positive things at North End resign
well I watched his news conference it
was pretty sad it was a sad look let
them figure out what to do but I felt
actually I felt sorry for his wife and
his wife saved him from doing as you
know Michael Jackson he was going to try
and imitate Michael Jackson with the
moonwalk
nobody can imitate Michael with the
moonwalk and this would not have been a
pretty you add that little couple of
seconds of footage on to what he did but
it was it was a pretty bad situation
mr. president thank thank you very very
much for being thank you very much
appreciate it